today I can report some very encouraging
information which has unfolded over the
last 24 hours
the towed pinger located deployed from
the australian defence vessel ocean
shield has detected signals consistent
with those emitted by aircraft black
boxes
two separate signal detection have
occurred within the northern part of the
defined search area clearly this is a
most promising rule
you
from deep beneath the ocean new sounds
mean a potential break through a series
of distinctive pings now being hailed as
a promising lead in the search for mh370
today I can report some very encouraging
information which has unfolded over the
last 24 hours the towed pinger locator
locator deployed from the Australian
Defense vessel ocean shield has detected
signals consistent with those emitted by
aircraft black boxes to separate signal
detection have occurred within the
northern part of the defined search area
significantly this would be consistent
with transmissions from both the flight
data recorder and the cockpit voice
recorder this is an international effort
in Malaysia the development brings
renewed hope ladies and gentlemen the
new developments over the last few hours
has been the most promising lead we have
had our edge all nations and the
international community to unite in
their prayers and not give up hope we
will continue with all our efforts to
find mh370
Australian and Chinese search crews have
been united in the race to find any sign
of the plane and its passengers first
Chinese teams said they'd located a ping
twice over two days the signal emitting
at a frequency of 37 point 5 kilohertz
that's exactly the same frequency the
locator device on the black box would be
transmitting we cannot confirm that the
pulse signal detected this afternoon
belongs to the black box of Malaysian
Airlines mh370 the information compiled
is being analyzed by China's maritime
rescue center and they are waiting for a
professional confirmation of the nature
of the signal but this new data from
Australian ship ocean shield is being
seen as the most significant using sound
detectors from the US Navy they picked
up two separate signals the first held
for more than two hours before they lost
contact is a very very slow and
painstaking process we have the best in
the world up there doing it though so
we're confident that if there is a the
ping up there and it's still radiating
we're quite confident that we should
find it we've got the best best in the
world
engaged in this task the two separate
pings picked up by the Australians were
over a thousand miles from Perth deep in
the Indian Ocean that's around 370 miles
north of where the Chinese ship detected
two pulses now investigators must
determine more precisely where the
signals are coming from and only then
can they deploy bluefin 21 the
underwater drone it was equipment like
this that was used to find the wreckage
of the Air France plane that crashed
into the Atlantic
the mini submarine can map out the ocean
floor and highlight potential pieces of
debris but it won't be straightforward
the uneven seabed is four and a half
kilometers down and that's the limit at
which the mini sub can operate what it's
doing is as the side scan is running and
it looks out and is getting returns back
from primarily hard objects that are
that are on the bottom all the rows in
the in the mission are put together in a
created a mosaic and you can look at
that and get an overall view of the
bottom and what what is there only once
the black box is finally spotted will
extra underwater machinery be deployed
with the delicate task of recovering the
recorder we set up grid patterns on the
computer and the ROV follows this search
pattern meticulously 5 metres apart we
go up and back and forth through the
whole debris field looking for the black
boxes the weather will be the biggest
consideration between the currents the
wind and weather patterns that will be
the biggest problem we might work one
day and have to sit around several days
waiting on weather to subside
the time and speed of this operation
remain crucial with battery life on the
locators limited the faint clicks will
begin to die out over the next day or so
and after that an almost impossible task
to become even harder this is a standard
civil underwater locator beacon and this
is a very common one for civil use
there's one of these attached to the
flight data recorder another one to the
cockpit voice recorder and it's
activated by this water switch when it
goes into the water driven by a battery
inside and that has a minimum 30 day
life and those leading research realized
the enormity of the task that they face
if the pingers are no longer
transmitting we're not gonna hear what
the towed pinger locator okay however
you know our focus right now is using
that because it has our greatest
detection range but after the period of
time when that towed when the acoustic
beacons are no longer emitting
eventually there needs to be a shift
into a side-scan sonar search much
shorter detection range much slower
process and I'm sure at that time you
know whether we acquire it or not with
the towed pinger locator now the area
we're in will certainly be a high
priority area to conduct that sonar
search all possible resources are being
dispatched 25 military and civilian
planes have been sent to the new search
zone
you
the Royal Navy will add its considerable
expertise to the hunt for the black box
survey ship HMS echo and submarine HMS
tireless are both equipped with
state-of-the-art sonar detecting
equipment that could tilt the odds in
favor of the search team the black box
is - believed to be about four and a
half kilometres down that's shallow
enough although it's not shallow it's
shallow enough to detect a black box you
can detect them down to about six
kilometers there have been if the
Chinese finding is verified then it's
already been picked up twice but further
ships are required to confirm the
finding and they will work together the
HMAS ocean shield which is towing the
pinger detector and then HMS echo which
is a very sophisticated survey ship
which has got a side-scan sonar and
various other sensors but also echo has
Moschino machinery for profiling the
ocean bottom so it can be improving the
the chart of the of the bottom of the
ocean there at the same time which is
going to be very very useful if it is
the black box and if we then want to
bring it up
watching this latest progress from afar
are of course the hundreds of families
waiting for news anything that could
tell them once and for all what has
happened
we are sent over the incident and we are
calling a mass prayer today to give a
positive energy to giving to give
strength to our nation and as such
rescue team to find and locate mh370 as
soon as possible
coming up in part two hopes of raised as
the relatives of the missing join in
prayer began those distinctive noises
deep in the ocean bring them any closer
to what happened to their loved ones for
weeks since their relatives went missing
this was time for prayer and
contemplation
as the sophisticated radars the
expensive hardware and the international
search teams hundreds of miles away try
to find them the answers that they need
239 people are presumed dead their
families desperate to know when they can
begin to grieve the power of prayer was
once again the only way that many could
cope with this ongoing ordeal we are
sent over the incident and we are
calling a mass prayer today to give a
positive energy to giving to give the
strength till our nation and a search
rescue team to find and locate mh370 as
soon as possible
but try as they might any indication
however a Moute the search for truth is
making progress raises the hopes of the
families they will soon discover what
happened to their missing loved ones it
will forever be painful anybody you lose
anybody you do not know what happened to
them it will always be very painful
always want to know what happened to the
plane I mean it has been a month and a
minister is a good find to do and until
they actually study the evidence and
what it belongs to and how is it
belonging to mh370 until then we go
we were we were home we were home
they know that this information could
still very much turn into another false
lead but it's hard to stop believing
when you have nothing else it's good
news
I hope the news will be confirmed and
they managed to find the black box
quickly so we will know the truth Philip
would a 50 year old American was
returning to Beijing following a
business trip he was about to leave
China for good to begin a new life with
Sarab a joke she was at home packing
boxes waiting for him to walk through
the front door when she heard the news I
do not believe the plane has crashed I
have yet to find any expert whom I've
talked to that off record has said that
they believe the plane has crashed
everybody believes has been taken I
absolutely believe he's still alive
about I still feel his presence I am NOT
a metaphysical weirdo I'm a very
grounded practical logical thinking
person but I still feel him in the same
way I have always felt him that has not
changed
you know I am prepared for if something
else happens if if if tomorrow I get the
notice that they've indeed found the
wreckage of the plane and Philips body
is still strapped in its seat then I
will accept that and I will move along
and deal with grief and a normal
grieving cycle but but this is not a
normal grieving cycle we don't have
resolution and there's no proof and
everything that I've heard both with my
head and with my intuition points that
there is some other resolution I can
only do so much to impact the situation
at this point and the little I can do is
to have an ongoing conversation with
media and to continue to drive forward
the social media efforts of getting
individuals to engage through the
finding Phillip wood Facebook page and
things but the other side of my of my
feeling is an increasing level of
anxiety that we don't have any further
progress on this I mean it's been
closing in on for weeks and we actually
don't know for sure anything different
than what we knew on the 8th we really
don't and I think we need a few more
truth seekers right now and a little
less jump on the bandwagon from our
governments and frankly in some ways
even our media there's no logical
explanation to support that this plane
was taken only to drop it into the water
there's none there's no evidence they've
found hundreds of pieces of debris none
of them are related to the plane you
know more and more we have to be a
little realistic here that says there's
got to be another there's got to be
another pass that was taken
in all the passenger manifests included
12 crew and 227 passengers from 14
different countries including New
Zealanders Australians Iranians
Americans and Indonesians two-thirds of
the passengers were from China among
them 43 year old father of two Nikolay
broadsky from Russia a professional
diver and athlete he traveled to
Indonesia on a diving holiday with
colleagues and was making his way home
when the flight went missing also Swan
and kala Kerr 23 years old from Mumbai
was travelling with his mother and
father to Beijing to attend his older
brothers degree ceremony their eldest
son waited at the airport for them for
several hours Rodney and Mary burrows
were among 6 Australians flying on the
plane traveling to Beijing with another
Australian couple a friend of them said
they planned a trip following Rodney's
redundancy the previous year
the Australian Chinese and Malaysian
authorities all know that these
distinctive pings could be hugely
significant but too often hopes have
been raised in the past four weeks
satellite images of debris turned out to
be nothing more than a ocean junk and
that is why all involved are again
urging caution we have been through a
real roller coaster ride based on leads
that we have received but as usual some
leads are much more positive than others
speaking to Angus Houston earlier today
I'm more optimistic than some of the
leads that we have had so I would like
everybody to continue to pray and this
is something that much more positive
than others but yet I'm very cautious
about seeing any more than that clearly
this is a most promising lead and
probably in the search so far it's the
it's probably the best information that
we have had and again I would ask all of
you to treat this information cautiously
and responsible responsibly until such
time as we can provide an unequivocal
determination we haven't found the
aircraft yet we need further
confirmation and I really stress this
it's very important
yet in this enormous expanse of ocean
the sounds from the deep have now given
new focus and drive this almost
impossible task there is still no sign
of wreckage or the 239 who are on board
no answers to what happened in those
final hours
but the possibility of finding the black
box and voice recorder could bring them
that vital step closer to finding flight
mh370
you